[موسيقى]
كيف حالك
في دبي رائد الأعمال السوري رونالدو
ميساوا هو ملك مبتدئ قصة
أصبحت أسطورة لكل
رائد أعمال شاب في جميع أنحاء المدينة
جئت للشراء عام 206 أتذكر حقًا
عدم وجود Google Facebook في  في الوقت الذي لم
يتم فيه ترجمة أي شيء في الجزء الخاص بنا من العالم ، فمن
الواضح أنه كانت هناك فرصة هائلة
مع أكثر من عقدين من الخبرة في
قطاع التكنولوجيا
أنشأ رونالدو أكبر موقع للتجارة الإلكترونية في المنطقة وهو
سوق هادئ منذ 14 عامًا
من اليوم الأول كل يوم حركة المرور
على  كان الموقع ينمو ، لذا في
صباح اليوم التالي ، سنلقي نظرة على التقارير ، فأنا على
ما يرام ، فنحن أكبر كنا نعلم أن لدينا
شيئًا له صدى جيدًا
مع العملاء وأعتقد أن
كل شيء لم يكن يعرف مدى
حجمه  صفقة بالمناسبة التي كنا
نتحدث عنها منذ فترة طويلة وفي
الداخل توجد فاتورة من السوق ، إنها
فاتورة لشراء أمازون لبدلة أما
أمازون فهي تنتقل إلى
الشرق الأوسط للحصول على l في المنطقة
تصدّر مشهد الشركات الناشئة المتنامي في دبي
عناوين الأخبار العالمية
في عام 2017 مع شراء أمازون لشركة رينالدو بقيمة 1/2 مليار دولار
بعد فترة وجيزة من
استحواذ شركة أوبر العالمية على شركة ناشئة محلية أخرى على كريم من قبل شركة النقل العالمية العملاقة أوبر
مقابل 3.1 مليار دولار.
نفس الشيء وهذا مهم
لأن مشاركة المعرفة هي جزء من
كيفية بناء شركتك ، فأنا أرشد العديد من
الأشخاص الآخرين وأعتقد أن التواجد حول أشخاص
قاموا بأشياء مماثلة في Able يحتاج
إلى التفكير بشكل أسرع للتعلم من
أخطائهم وهذا هو الإرشاد
والوصول إلى الإعجابات  رونالدو الذي
بدأ يؤتي ثماره
لمشهد الشركات الناشئة في دبي